- Holy crap man, I
thought you were kidding.
(laughs)
- Where better to play
Dungeons and Dragons than
in your own dungeon?
- (laughs) It's crazy.
- What? What's so funny?
- Oh, you're just this huge
hunk.
- Please, come on. You
know I'm a total nerd.
I mean I've got one of those,
that thing right over there,
bunch of these.
- Hey, I've got an idea.
Last season of Game of Thrones,
let's watch it together.
Guy's night.
- Are you kidding?
Yes!
- Right?
- Who's gonna sit on the Iron
Stone?
(electronic squelch)
Cone. The cone. The Iron Cone.
- It's "Iron Throne."
You know that, Joe, right?
- (laughs) Just kiddin', man.
It's a joke.
- Okay.
- Excuse me.
- Sure.
- [Joe] Hey man, what
the fuck! It's Throne!
You're making me look
like an idiot in there!
- [Man In Hall] I'm so
sorry sir, it must be
the equipment, I don't know.
- [Joe] Just shut up
and do your fuckin' job!
So uh, Sophia's gonna whip up
some
chocolate chip cookies,
should be done any second.
- That didn't sound like Sophia,
Joe.
- Oh, we haven't geeked
out on Infinity War.
- We haven't! We haven't,
actually.
It was crazy.
Which death hit you the hardest?
(electronic feedback)
- Oh, god damn it!
- What's wrong? You okay?
- Um, yeah. What were we talking
about?
- Infinity War. Which
death hit you the hardest?
- Oh, right. Which death in
Infinity War
hit me the hardest?
- [Man In Hall] I can't
hear you, it's not working!
- Which death in Infinity
War hit me the hardest?
- [Man In Hall] Which death?
Spider-Man!
- Spider-Man. Duh.
Excuse me.
- Sure.
- [Joe] Dude all this equipment
is shit!
Why are you even here?
- I'm sorry, we're
subterranean, so it's hard
for the waves to travel through
the walls.
- What is this, Joe?
- This is my friend Taron.
- Hello.
- He lives in this hallway.
- [Taron] I do, and I don't
feed Joe nerd knowledge
through an IFB that isn't
working today.
- Taron!
- I said I don't do that.
- Why?
Why Joe, why do this? Why do any
of this?
- Because it's not enough
to be a stud anymore.
Nerds have taken over.
Back in the 80's,
I just beat the crap
out of dorks like you.
But I can't anymore.
Now guys like Taron are in
charge.
But I mean, look at him. He
deserves it.
He's got kind eyes and sexual
dynamism
I can never live up to.
That's why he's the great--
What the? Now you get
the ear piece to work!
- I'm just gonna head out now, I
think.
- Master, he knows too much.
- What, no.
- You're not gonna tell
anybody about this, are you?
- You should stay, Josh.
We're just about to play Pogs.
- Right. You like Pogs, don't
you?
- Joe has the biggest slammer.
- You guys are coming back soon,
right?
- [Sophia] Joe, Taron, cookies!
- Be there in a second, honey!
- Mm, I hope she's making
her snickerdoodles.
- No, no, no, no, no, no!
It's really dark in here.
- [Sophia] Is your little
friend staying for cookies?